suman las dos expresiones y combina
términos semejantes y bueno tengo estas
dos expresiones de aquí y para eso
déjame sacar mi libreta de notas suma
las dos expresiones y combina términos
semejantes y tengo un 62 menos dos
tercios menos bien y bueno como quiero
combinar términos semejantes entonces
déjame apuntar los justo aquí me va a
quedar
déjeme agarrar este color el color azul
y me va a quedar 6 ie6
y más 2 ok
a esto le voy a sumar menos dos tercios
menos james a esto
le voy a sumar menos dos tercios menos
10 de lujo y bueno en primer lugar tengo
6 10 ya esto le voy a quitar 1 james
si tengo 6 algo y le quitó una vez ese
algo me queda con 5 veces ese algo 6
james menos ya es lo mismo que cinco
veces y ok esto está de lujo y después
tengo esta parte de aquí más
dos menos dos tercios y bueno eso lo
podemos resolver de este lado tengo dos
menos dos tercios y es que dos lo
podemos escribir en tercios de la
siguiente manera como seis tercios seis
entre tres es lo mismo que dos ok menos
dos tercios y bueno seis tercios menos
dos tercios esto es lo mismo que cuatro
tercios que cuatro tercios y por lo
tanto me va a quedar cinco y más cuatro
tercios si simplificó estas expresiones
que tengo aquí después de sumarlas llegó
al resultado de cinco yemas cuatro
tercios ahora es justo el momento de
sacar aquí mi navegador
tengo justo por aquí y escribir nuestra
respuesta correcta aquí voy a escribir
cinco veces bien cinco veces y ya esto
le voy a sumar le voy a sumar cuatro
tercios cuatro tercios y bueno puedes
verificar que si lo interpretó de una
manera correcta y es hora de comprobar
la respuesta de lujo estamos bien